blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman all right i want to start today
with the coronavirus update i think it's
useful to do this
um at least once a week last week people
seem to appreciate it
and because i look at this stuff every
day i assume
that everybody has all the same
information i have and
we learned a long time ago when we were
kids what happens when one assumes and i
don't want to do that so
let's do the coronavirus update i have
cautiously good news
uh about cases and deaths and vaccines
and we're going to discuss the
coronavirus
variants and and let's get right into it
so first of all cases
last week i told you that after peaking
around january 11th
average daily coveted cases were down
about 42 percent as of early last week
and i said at the beginning of last week
by the end of last week meaning friday
we would probably be down 50 percent in
terms of daily cases
from that peak on january 11th and we
reached that milestone and we have now
surpassed that milestone covid average
daily cases in the united states
are down to 110 000 still an insane
number 110
000 cases a day on average but that's a
56 decline
from the peak on january 11th so
in basically four weeks average case is
down 56 percent
which puts us roughly where we were back
on november
10th and hopefully that will continue to
decline if cases continue declining at
the same rate that they have been since
january 11th
we'd be down to about 48 000 cases a day
by the beginning of march
it's unlikely that this will be a
straight-line decline
there will be changes there will be
inflection points
but um this is a very very good piece of
news
and we will talk about how the variance
may affect these numbers now what about
deaths
we've previously mentioned at this point
everybody's probably sick of hearing me
say
death slag cases by about three to four
weeks
we would expect that if cases peak on
january 11th
deaths would be peaking and starting to
decline around
now is that happening yes it appears to
be happening
deaths hit an average peak of about 3
400 deaths per day around the middle of
january
more than a 911 every single day
the trend line sort of plateaued and it
has started to come down
and hopefully will start to come down
more
uh quickly as people are vaccinated
particularly folks at highest risk of
death
so that gets us to variance and to get
to variants we have to go through
vaccines currently there are two
vaccines
approved for emergency use in the united
states
first was the pfizer vaccine than the
moderna vaccine
early concerns about
supply and delivery have been replaced
by more cautious optimism from pfizer
and moderna
about their ability to continue
delivering millions of doses per day
as many of you know i was on a sort of
on-call list for leftover doses at the
end of the day a friend of mine works at
a hospital that has a
zero waste commitment on doses and
i was able to get my first dose of the
modern vaccine about 10 days ago from a
left overdose
from cancelled appointments and the
numbers continue to improve the us is
now giving out
an average of 1.46 million doses per day
remember joe biden's goal
was 1 million doses per day for 100 days
we're at 1.46 million doses per day and
on saturday and sunday the u.s actually
did
2 million doses each day 2 million on
saturday
2 million on sunday that is absolutely
fantastic
if we get a third vaccine approved in
the next three weeks
johnson johnson has submitted their
vaccine for approval that's a one
dose vaccine not inconceivable
that the u.s could get to 2.5 million
doses per day i mean i want to be
careful but
even 3 million doses per day which would
be
absolutely fantastic and the one dose
nature of the jnj vaccine
makes the legit the logistics even
easier
now case is down death's starting to
come down
vaccination starting to go up what about
the covet variants there is a lot of
doom and gloom about the covet variants
from the uk
from brazil and from south africa lots
of people being very dire about this
some even saying the vaccines just
flat out don't work against the variants
so what is the truth
uh the truth is really not that bad uh
what we know uh we know the astrazeneca
vaccine
which is not even approved in the u.s
yet really doesn't seem effective
against that south african
variant that's bad they're having
problems moving forward okay
the pfizer and moderna vaccines which
are approved in the united states
seem the way i would characterize it
colloquially
without making a mathematical statement
is the pfizer and modern vaccines appear
to be quite effective against the
variants including the south african
variant now
it is true early data suggests
you are less protected against the south
african variant
with the pfizer and modern vaccines it
doesn't mean you are unprotected
people immune responses on a bell curve
as
many of you know and we've looked at and
those
with a stronger immune response to the
vaccines
are probably still protected against the
south african variant
and protected against the british
variant that's the b117 variant and
and the brazilian variant but very
importantly
this is not a reason not to get
vaccinated it's
a reason to get vaccinated as quickly as
possible the virus mutates as it spreads
every time that the virus goes from one
person to another is an
opportunity for a mutation the more
people you get vaccinated
now fewer cases less mutation
fewer variants okay moderna and pfizer
are
studying the variants they are
developing as a sort of insurance policy
a modified booster shot but that's eight
nine
ten months away based on my current
understanding
so we don't yet know what the approval
process will be from an fda standpoint
for modified vaccines so what we can do
now
is there's no point in waiting if you're
eligible for a vaccine get the vaccine
because
if you prevent an infection or two
infections or three infections by being
vaccinated
even if eventually the british south
south african and or
brazilian variants become the dominant
strains the more people that have
partial protection the better there's no
argument for
delaying there is a debate now about
what happens in three months so we've
talked about
cases are coming down quickly deaths
have leveled and are starting to come
down but the variants are spreading
there are some the most pessimistic
perspective who say the variants are
going to take over the vaccines will not
work against them
and cases will explode again to the
level we saw
in december i don't think that's the
most likely scenario
based on all of the um epidemiological
data i've seen
and interviews and statements and
writing from immunologists and
epidemiologists
if we keep vaccinating the january 11th
peak will likely be the final
major peak as the weather starts to
improve in the parts of the country
that have winter and more and more
people are vaccinated
yes it is likely true that more and more
of the cases will be the variance but it
is also
true that more and more millions and
tens of millions and hopefully hundreds
of millions of americans
will have uh sufficient protection
against
these variants that cases will continue
to decline now
when we get to then we'll have summer
etc
when we get to the next flu season
in the fall hopefully by then
there will be a modified booster if
indeed it's determined that that's
what's necessary
and my hope is and i believe it's
realistic
but cautious is that the january 11th
peak was
the final peak for this pandemic
um all we can do now is continue to be
safe
continue to vaccinate and i i've
mentioned this before
we should not undersell the vaccine i i
know people who were saying
listen i'm being told even if you get
vaccinated it may not work against the
variants
and you still have to wear a mask you
still have to social distance there are
lots of good
immunologists and epidemiologists who
are saying listen in in a month if these
the numbers continue going this way
if you are fully vaccinated meaning a
week past dose two
it's it's a very acceptable level of
risk to have an indoor dinner with six
fully vaccinated people let's be
realistic about what this means it
doesn't mean
you go to the grocery store and you say
i don't have to wear a mask because i'm
vaccinated that's going to be the policy
for some time
in parts of the country i know friends
in places like arizona are telling me
nobody's wearing a mask at the grocery
store but in much of the country that's
what's going on it'll continue to go on
but let's be realistic about
the game-changing nature of these
vaccines we'll check in about the data
again
uh next week donald trump's impeachment
trial starts today now we're going to
talk about
in a bit after the break what is the
argument that donald trump is making
about the impeachment
what is the argument that his lawyers
will make about the impeachment but
first let's talk about what should
happen in this impeachment
if this was a fair world where actions
had consequences even if you're the
president
there should be probably a secret ballot
for impeachment
so that senators would not be bullied
into voting to acquit merely to avoid
what might be the political consequences
there should be a secret ballot and
there should be a unanimous conviction
of donald trump
based on the evidence that we've seen
now there's a really good article an
op-ed in the hill
i hope i'm pronouncing his last name
correctly it's douglas meek kmiec i hope
i'm pronouncing that correctly
and uh douglas points out that the
entire
argument that will take up the first day
in today's senate impeachment trial
which is
is the impeachment trial even
constitutional
that is not the duty of the senate to
determine
the duty of the senate is not to
determine whether this is constitutional
first of all it is
and secondly why would you put many
non-legal scholars non-legal
professionals in a position of deciding
about the constitutionality of something
it really doesn't make sense
what jurors in the senate should be
determining
is whether donald trump could reasonably
foresee
that the consequences of him saying
it's all rigged for a month or two
months let's go down to the capitol
we're marching down to the capitol
rudy giuliani you know trial by combat
all of this stuff
could it was it foreseeable that the
uncontested reality of what took place
was something uh that that was likely to
take place
that is what the determination
ultimately needs to be
donald trump doesn't have the law on his
side when it comes to avoiding
um impeachment because of some
constitutional issue but in any case
that's not really
what the senate should be deciding and
there is really no disagreement
about what took place on january 6. this
douglas meek points out
even trump's defense team acknowledges
the facts
of what took place on january 6th which
was a violent
uh insurrection attempt at the u.s
capitol so then it becomes
a question of really common sense
remember this is not a court of law the
senate
uh was was it reasonable for donald
trump to foresee
what took place and it's very hard to
imagine that the answer is no
donald trump was reportedly gleeful in
the early hours of the insurrection
donald trump reportedly resisted sending
law enforcement which would have quelled
or or limited
what took place and only when donald
trump
was convinced that the political
consequences could be too grave
did he come out and give that
mealy-mouthed sort of
uh statement about oh we've got to be
peaceful and all of this stuff
so that's what should happen trump won't
be convicted
and the voting won't be by secret ballot
i was
i was actually thinking imagine that
there was a secret ballot where instead
of voting out loud publicly
senators voted secretly um imagine that
you end up with 80 votes to convict
so you know 30 republicans voted to
convict
but none of them are willing to admit it
you know what would happen right they
would again start with voter fraud
supposedly 80 votes to convict and we
can't find a single republican willing
to say yes i voted to convict
but you know what it's going to be a
moot point because they're not going to
convict
and then it will be up to voters to
determine
whether they care enough to force
consequences upon these republican
senators in the 2022 election now as
a reminder when we talk about
representative democracy
a majority of americans say that donald
trump should be convicted and barred
from holding office in the future 56
percent of americans
we looked at that abc poll yesterday uh
trump's lawyers
are saying that the entire trial is
merely political theater
and the arguments that they are making
uh in their
early legal brief and we will see today
and tomorrow more so
how they actually make this case a
reality they are both saying
that uh the entire process is
unconstitutional
and that the house's impeachment vote
was extraordinarily biased
and they are going to say that this is
censorship and it's an attempt to
silence donald trump and of course
that's not what it is uh donald trump
was able to say whatever the hell he
wanted
and now there may be consequences to him
saying that remember
free speech doesn't mean freedom from
all consequences to your speech
one other little note apparently trump's
defense team is planning to show clips
of what they say
are examples of democrats urging
violence from last year
so i think that there's going to be a
lot of interesting moments during this
but ultimately we are going to get the
political theater is going to be trump's
defense
we are going to get an acquittal and
then ultimately we will see if the
american people decide that these
republican senators need to be held
accountable the american public often
has a short memory
so i am not particularly optimistic that
republican senators
uh who have prejudged this and already
know they are going to acquit
will be held accountable it would be
nice if they were but i don't anticipate
that
and we will be live streaming the
impeachment on the david pakman show
youtube twitch and facebook channels i
hope you'll join me but in the meantime
let me know via twitter what you expect
to see
in this trial you can find me on twitter
at deepakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription when you
go to blinkist dot com slash david
pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
our program is mostly funded by viewers
and listeners through the david pakman
show membership program
grab a membership at joinedpakman.com
you'll get the daily
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
and you'll be supporting us which just
feels great you can also use the coupon
code better21
all one word better21 to save
hugely off of your membership of choice
at joinpakman.com
donald trump has published i can't say
for sure that he's written it maybe he
did maybe he just
had it published i don't know but donald
trump has published a letter about the
impeachment trial that starts today
now recall that donald trump is the only
president in history to be impeached
twice
and his second trial starts today the
first day
of debate is actually going to be about
whether the impeachment trial is
constitutional
if that gets 51 votes or 50 50 with
kamala harris as the tiebreaker
saying that the trial is constitutional
then the trial will sort of start in
earnest
tomorrow so donald trump wrote a letter
yesterday
arguing that the trial is not
constitutional donald trump wrote from
the office of donald j trump with a sort
of presidential looking seal
statement on the next phase of the
unconstitutional impeachment trial
president donald j trump's legal team
issued the following statement regarding
the next phase
of the unconstitutional impeachment
trial
president trump and his counsel are
pleased that there was bipartisan
support
on how to structure the impeachment
trial we appreciate
that senate republican leadership stood
strong
for due process and secured a structure
that is consistent with past precedent
the past precedent by the way uh this
process will provide us
with an opportunity to explain to
senators
why it is absurd and unconstitutional
to hold an impeachment trial against
a private citizen now hilariously
the letter has the presidential seal at
the top
it says president donald j trump's legal
team
it says president trump and then it says
it's all unconstitutional because this
is just a private citizen this is just
some guy
uh you can't do this i've never seen
private citizens
use the seal in letterhead for private
letters it's very interesting that
donald trump is doing that now
i know he gets the title president
for life but if you want to play up
the unconstitutionality of the trial
based on trump being a private citizen
maybe play down the references to
president trump
maybe don't have the presidential seal
taking up half the page
and uh i i can't believe i'm saying this
but
if a private citizen incited an
insurrection that would
also be a big deal and we're actually
going to talk about
the criminal aspect a little bit later
when we look at some statements from
senator rand paul about this but it's
being overlooked
that private citizens also would have
repercussions for inciting insurrection
so
the trump legal team and trump together
it's like the blind leading the blind
they want to pretend he's still
president but also say he can't be tried
because he's not the president anymore
and the logic doesn't pass the sniff
test
if a ceo of a company is
uh charged for embezzling and then fired
and at the time of the trial they've
been fired right they're no longer the
ceo
could they say well you can't i don't i
don't work there anymore
you can't try me for embezzling
embezzlement i'm not there anymore
uh this is the exact same thing that's
going on with donald trump he was by the
way
impeached while in office trump was
still pres not that it matters
but trump was impeached while in office
so imagine being
i don't know one of these lawyers and
having to deal with donald trump right
now
and it probably explains this letter
seeing this letter
explains much of why many of trump's
lawyers quit last week
and on the merits it's completely
constitutional
even if they had not impeached trump
until after he was president it would
still be constitutional
but trump was president when he was
impeached this is merely the trial so
there is no good legal argument for why
the trial can't happen after trump is
out of office
trump is a scam this is all a scam
and from the point of view of trump's
unending narcissism he's also planning
to have his lawyers portray him as the
victim during these entire proceedings
and i want to talk about that uh next
there's a very interesting article in
the new republic which we're going to
link to the article is by a matt ford
and we've um we've talked about matt
ford's work before and it's often
very very good and in this new republic
piece
matt ford uh talks about the reality
that there is quote no real substantive
defense to these charges the charges
against donald trump
americans watched trump spread lies
about the elections
for months before the riot he warned in
dark and ominous terms that the country
was in danger and his supporters needed
to fight back
trump said at a rally outside the
capitol on january 6 you'll never take
back our country with weakness
you have to show strength you have to be
strong we have to come to demand that
congress do the right thing
and only count the electors that have
been lawfully slated
lawfully slated he also even praised his
supporters
after they trampled themselves and beat
up police officers as quote
very special so this is a situation
where the facts are abundantly clear
and yet donald trump is going to portray
himself as the victim
in these proceedings the main line as
matt ford writes of defense from trump's
lawyers
is that the impeachment trial is in that
invalid because trump no longer holds
federal
office but also that trump really here
is actually the victim trump has been
victimized on free speech grounds trump
has been silenced
trump isn't being allowed to speak this
is a form of censorship
cancel culture blah blah blah blah blah
and that trump is being by tried in this
manner
stripped of first amendment protections
now of course
that's a ridiculous argument uh house
managers
already put out a brief about this and
they explained that
the first amendment is there to protect
americans
from having their free speech uh
infringed upon or curtailed by
the government it's not there to protect
members of the government
from their speech having consequences
speech
has consequences that's part of free
speech
and so at its core
this is simple gaslighting and i know
that at this point there's so many
people particularly on the american
right
who instantly become triggered when the
term gaslighting is mentioned
this is not uh this trial is not going
to be about
the trump attorney team putting together
a credible
defense the entire idea of trump as
victim
who has lost his free speech rights is
about
putting up a smoke screen so that
most i don't want to say all but most
republican senators will see if any vote
to convict
most republican senators can vote to
acquit
and hide behind this and say it wasn't
and actually part of today being about
whether the trial is constitutional is
set up
so that you can have republican senators
vote to acquit and say listen
i didn't even think this was
constitutional i did my duty i think the
entire thing was farcical
it was unconstitutional and i voted to
acquit and
this is a very common thing that bullies
do it's a common thing that narcissists
do
they are the perpetrators but they
pretend to be the bullies
authoritarians are always the victims
strong men
are always pretending to be the
aggrieved and we've seen it with kim
jong-un
we saw it with hugo chavez they are
all endlessly the victims forever and
ever
and that's what donald trump will try
starting today at his impeachment trial
through lawyers by arguing the entire
thing is unconstitutional trump's out of
office
this all can't happen once we get to the
actual trial
they will argue that this is a matter of
speech and censorship
and trump is being victimized here by
you know take your pick
the media democrat whatever just pick
pick whatever you want
um and at this point i would be
surprised if you were surprised because
donald trump has been playing the victim
forever during the 2016 campaign
he was constantly whining about how
unfair everybody was to him the media is
unfair democrats are unfair nobody's
treating him
properly and uh there i mean i have a
i have a sort of um i don't know
a sort of macabre detached curiosity
to see how wacky and deranged the case
made by trump's defense lawyers is going
to be
and by the time you listen to today's
show by the time you watch this clip we
will probably already have a sense of it
because the
impeachment trial starts today we will
have coverage and much more about this
on the david pakman show instagram uh
page
make sure you're following us there at
david pakman show we will take a quick
break and be right back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in and
day out
you can sign up for membership very very
quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show i
want to talk today about the issue of
transgender sports participation and
maybe even more
specifically about trans women in sports
and there's a really specific reason why
i want to do this last week i got a call
and as many of you know
when we do calls they can be about
anything i'm not prepared for them i'm
just answering and
the topics can be anything and i give my
thoughts at the time
and someone called in who said they're
on the left
they're not transphobic they support
trans rights
at every opportunity and yet they said
they recognize
that having individuals born
biologically male
participating in women's sports confers
an advantage at a physical level
that didn't make sense to them and i
said not knowing a lot about it
that i also didn't fully understand the
logic
but i was aware of the fact that the
right often cynically wants to make this
the issue about trans rights when the
reality is it's really not the major
issue that that make it out to be
and it's often used as a way to subtly
push back against trans rights more
broadly and today i want to expand on my
comments because
i actually had some time over the
weekend to research the issue in more
detail and the more i learn about it the
more convinced i am
that it is a fabricated wedge issue
meant to divide people and in particular
to predispose people to be against
trans rights as i researched the issue
one of the things i learned
is that hormone replacement therapy
which trans women
often avail themselves of over a one to
two year period
comes close to completely eliminating
the performance gap that we
might imagine exists in some sports when
you have individuals born biologically
male
competing against those born
biologically female
now i want to put aside for a second the
absolutely hysterical notion that
some cisgendered men might quote pretend
to be trans women
and go through testosterone blocking
treatment merely to compete
in women's sports without actually
genuinely being
trans someone willing to do that has
bigger issues that need to be resolved
but it's it's it's so uncommon
that it's not really the issue the
reality is that a study from 2015
called race times for transgender
athletes
shows that trans women have essentially
no advantage in running
over cisgendered women after a period of
roughly a year
of hormone replacement therapy there's
another more recent study which showed
that
after one year there is still a modest
advantage for trans women
and that the length of time with the
hormone replacement therapy
maybe should be longer but to get from
that the idea that this is some kind of
you know woke cabal looking to impose
mike tyson or his physical equivalent
into women's wrestling against 18 year
old girls as an
example that's a cartoon that that's
ridiculous to suggest that that's
predominantly the situation that that
exists in the world and i got a few
dozen emails about this
and i was completely genuine when i said
last week
i've not studied this enough but at face
value
it does raise some questions for me i
still believe this is a complicated
issue
but the issue of trans sports is one of
many issues related to trans rights and
its importance is being dramatically
inflated by certain groups of people
for cynical political goals and what i
mean by that is that
trans people intersex individuals they
didn't just start existing in the last
five years
sports organizations endocrinologists
and others they've known about this for
a really long time and
many institutions deal with these things
on a case-by-case basis so
when i hear about a political movement
that has this knee-jerk reaction to
immediately say
no trans women in women's sports period
it either is coming from
just an ignorant place or a place of
very bad faith so
i'm glad to have learned more about it
and to be able to say more and that
doesn't mean all my questions are
answered
with a whole bunch of sports this is not
really an issue
with a certain category of sports this
is in theory an issue
and we have to look at hormone
replacement therapy actual performance
differences after one or two year
periods
and i tweeted about this yesterday and a
few people wrote to me and they said oh
but there's this particular case where
someone's skull was broken by a trans
woman okay
i'm not saying that there are no issues
what i
am saying is that pretending this is the
issue about
trans rights is wrong
i'm not going to say necessarily that
it's coming from
bad faith it could be ignorance but it's
wrong to say this is the issue
it has to be dealt with on a
case-by-case basis and the other thing i
would point out is
the people that were replying to my
tweet kept talking about the two or
three individual instances
where else would these folks say that
because of two or three
instances of something we need to
completely change
all of the legal and regulatory
infrastructure uh
look at the number of people that are
killed by guns and yet they say oh yeah
but i mean you know a few hundred
incidents that's
that's not enough to justify changing
the rules uh but yet here
everybody's pointing to the same two or
three incidents over the last five years
and saying that justifies
creating an entirely new regulatory and
legal apparatus it just doesn't pass the
sniff test for me and i've been glad to
to learn more about it
doesn't mean every question is answered
doesn't mean that there aren't some
problems to solve or questions to deal
with uh but i think we need to
understand the sort of cynical nature
that exists by
among those who pretend this is the
issue and
um use it as a smoke screen to deny
trans rights more broadly and
unfortunately that's what's happening
all too often
we learned yesterday that jared kushner
and ivanka trump
earned somewhere between 172 million
dollars
and 640 million dollars in what is
called outside income while working
in the white house during the presidency
of donald trump
this was a financial analysis done by
crew citizens for a responsibility and
ethics
in washington i i forget exactly what
crew stands for
they looked at financial disclosures and
uh you might remember that
donald trump famously said he would
donate a salary and jared kushner would
be an
unpaid adviser to trump and ivanka would
be an unpaid advisor to no none of them
were taking salaries while working for
the government
and that was supposed to prove there's
no nepotism and there's no concerns or
whatever
and of course they continued to make
massive amounts of money from their
stakes for example ivanka trump's stake
in trump's hotel in dc
which was frequented and patronized by
uh world leaders and diplomats
in order to ingratiate themselves with
donald trump
we saw all sorts of uh ivanka's
businesses including related to i think
it was handbags and whatever else even
sometimes promoted
on national television by paid adviser
to trump kellyanne conway
we saw all of it and they made an insane
amount of money
while working in the white house
advising a sitting president but
but but what about hunter biden right i
thought that was the issue
imagine making as much as
two-thirds of a billion dollars over
four years
while working a government job at the
highest level
now in reality family should simply be
banned from serving in
any position whatsoever for the federal
government
when a family member is president at
minimum
no matter what you're doing you should
have to be senate confirmed
now this is of course uh in addition to
the fact that they cost the american
people
and taxpayers way more money ivanka and
jared
through their constant trips secret
service protection and the whole thing
so yeah it's truly shocking you might
remember
and we're already seeing a lot of
responses about this people saying well
look
the clintons became super wealthy after
bill clinton was president barack obama
became super wealthy
after he was president yes that's after
after they weren't making millions and
hun
hundreds of millions of dollars during
their white house years and you know
this is a reality yeah bernie's a
millionaire he's also almost 80.
uh and at this point if you've been
making you know six figures
for 30 years uh unless you're really bad
with money you would be a millionaire
presidents end up making a lot of money
because people hire them for speeches
after they're out of office
they get a cushy book deal but this
isn't even the president this is the
president's kids
while working at the white house making
somewhere between
172 million and 640 million
dollars um so you can't really what
about your way
out of that one now meanwhile um
we don't really know what the future is
of many of these trump businesses a lot
of the trump
real estate holdings losing value over
the last four years
half the country close to half the
country won't even go to trump hotels
anymore for political reasons and we
know the dc hotel is struggling and a
lot of these
others are struggling that is all true
but it doesn't mean that these four
years weren't extremely profitable for
this family and so
when trump said he would drain the swamp
um
he obviously didn't do it but the
personal
uh incomes of these individuals while he
was in
office are absolutely and completely
stunning so
they're all going to be fine you know
some people feeling bad that
jared and ivanka aren't welcome back in
the social circles in manhattan where
they
previously uh uh were regulars don't
feel bad for them they're going to be
fine
they were able to work high-profile
government jobs i know they didn't have
a salary i know
continue making hundreds of millions of
dollars and
they they are going to do just fine and
they did much of it on the backs of
taxpayer dollars that's the reality
uh we will take a quick break the trump
impeachment trial number two starts
today we'll be covering it live
i have fox clips coming up i have
voicemails coming up and so many more
things
glad you're with me today the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you're wondering how does the david
pakman show afford to exist
the answer is mostly through memberships
in patreon you can support the work we
do by signing up for membership at
joinpakman.com
or pledging as little as a dollar a
month at patreon.com
david pakman show perks include the
daily bonus show the commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
and the positive feelings that come from
doing the right thing
and making hatreds cry through your
support of independent progressive
media jump in today at joinpackman.com
and patreon.com davidpakmanshow
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
throughout the donald trump presidency i
would often jokingly say whatever
happened to that migrant caravan
coming to the united states border from
mexico and of course it was a joke
referencing the completely
capricious and arbitrary nature of how
the trump republican party and
republicans more broadly
go back to the same refrains when it's
convenient for them
trump had a crazy phone call with
ukraine well it's infrastructure week at
the white house republicans propose an
insane
health care plan that would lead to 24
million people losing coverage
well the migrant caravan is coming and
democrats don't care
laura ingram literally ran a segment
yesterday called joe biden's
insurrection
yeah i know donald trump's second
impeachment trial starts today
because he incited the january sixth
insurrection
yes joe biden has a higher approval
rating already than donald trump
ever did during his entire presidency
yes
republicans are standing in opposition
to a coveted relief bill that's popular
with the majority of the country yes
the majority of americans wants donald
trump convicted so it's time
for biden's insurrection
let's um take a look at these clips
which as
laura ingram will explain to us is joe
biden
welcoming undocumented immigrants to the
united states
let's check out the clips fox news
apparently realizing they need to out
crazy oan and newsmax to get back
some of the audience that they've lost
now that takes us back to tomorrow's
barnum bailey revival in the senate
democrats are arguing that trump
welcomed and incited
a violent incursion into the capital
when it is they who are enticing
illegals
to bust through our borders exploit our
resources
and commit crimes and we're not talking
about a few hundred
we're talking hundreds of thousands
eventually millions
if the democrats have their way even for
fox news this is really a stretch
at this point i don't even know if the
fox news audience
believes this at least not a huge
portion of it but
some of them do let's listen to some
more and she really crams in
a lot of hate xenophobia misdirection
red herrings into this one short clip
there is an insurrection taking place
against america all right
it's been going on for years in the
deepest depth of the dc swamp
and now its figurehead resides at 1600
pennsylvania avenue
this insurrection seeks to overthrow
everything we love about america
by defaming it silencing it and even
prosecuting it
this is an organized mob funded by
billionaires
it's supported by celebrities and it's
aided and abetted by propagandistic
news organizations every single step of
the way
these insurrectionists have stormed our
schools with blm indoctrinators
they shuttered our classrooms by
empowering union heavies
they've overwhelmed small businesses
with idiotic
stupid lockdowns they've robbed
americans of good paying oil and gas
jobs with obscene climate change
dictates
they've ripped down historical markers
from washington
to lincoln they've terrorized patriotic
americans
who are now afraid to just speak their
minds
they burn police precincts they've taken
over entire city blocks
and not just for a few hours by the way
but for weeks
this is the sort of brown people are
going to take your house
portion of laura ingraham's program
and um this is actually a lot of what
these faux populists are right-wing
populists were they sort of sound like
populists but
their solutions are bonkers often they
end up at black lives matter will take
your house brown people will take your
job sort of stuff
and in that short clip black lives
matter is bad mexican immigrants are bad
liberal celebrities are bad coveted
guidelines are bad
getting away with fossil getting away
from fossil fuels is bad
climate change is fake confederate
monuments are good
and it's so heavily weaponized that it's
difficult to believe that it's even real
i mean it looks like an
snl skit of a fox news show
if fox news decided to run a test where
they said
let's test our audience to see
what's the dumbest and craziest thing we
can
get them to believe how about this let's
pretend joe biden is leading an
insurrection
this is what that test would look like
and
we've seen you know we wondered a month
ago what would a post-trump fox news
look like
fox news no longer covers coveted
briefings which are happening by the way
fox news rarely covers white house press
briefings
which are happening and it's this type
of stuff now
fighting for the most extreme audience
they can and there's a real question as
to whether they believe
that that is the audience they need to
be profitable
in other words if what they were losing
to oan and newsmax
were not a particularly profitable piece
of their audience
they wouldn't necessarily need to be
doing this to get that audience back but
they're doing it and there must be a
reason for it and of course the really
scary part is
that you and i see this we know every
word is a lie
it's it's like when it was the migrant
caravan during the trump era right
it's all made up it's all fake
there are millions of people in this
country though where you sit them
down and you show them that commentary
from laura ingraham
and they believe it and they think that
forget about they think it's good
reporting they think it's reporting
uh rather than just the rantings of of
laura ingraham
and it's a systemic problem and when we
talk about i i don't want to do my whole
rant now but
when we talk about epistemology when we
talk about media literacy when we talk
about
identifying logical fallacies and
distinguishing between
statements of fact and statements of
opinion opinion programming news
programming all of these things
the net effect is laura ingraham does
that
and a lot of people come away thinking i
have now been informed by a news report
which is of course the furthest thing
from what that actually was
this is very interesting to see
republican senator
and trump brown-noser rand paul
went on fox news this weekend and tried
to pawn off on fox news host chris
wallace this
silly notion that donald trump can't be
tried
for his impeachment uh after being out
of office
now remember that even though legally
trump can be impeached after leaving
office
he was impeached while in office but the
trial is happening afterwards it's
happening
now there's nothing unconstitutional
about this there's really nothing
particularly remarkable remarkable about
that but rand paul tries
that failed argument on chris wallace
and chris wallace
shuts it down and rightly so let's look
at the first clip the other side argues
that under that standard a president
could abuse his power quit
at the last minute and could not be held
accountable by the senate for
obviously if it's if it's a legal crime
he could be but for a political crime
the senate would be unable to touch him
under your standard
i think that argument ignores the fact
that yes the president can be prosecuted
and if they think he incited a riot or
an insurrection
which is such an overstatement and such
a conclusion
without any sort of presentation of
evidence all the left-wing media just
concludes it
but the thing is is yes they can take
him to court they can take him to trial
and do it
i think he has suffered under public
opinion his numbers are greatly reduced
and so i think there's all kinds of
punishment but we have to look we've had
a country for 250 years
and every other congress thought it was
unwise to keep you know
going after an ex-president so that's
actually
super slippery of rand paul rand paul
throws together a bunch of different
arguments there now they're all bad
arguments but when you put them all
together
it sounds sort of like wow that that was
a lot of arguments lots of
reasons why trump can't be tried now
but don't let him gish gallop you let's
actually think through each of the
arguments
first rand paul says if trump incited
uh if trump incited an insurrection
there can be legal repercussions
trump could be charged criminally trump
could be prosecuted criminally
he could be convicted he could be
sentenced criminal criminally now that's
first of all a red herring because it
has nothing to do with the house and
senate the house and senate don't have
that power
the house and senate don't have the
responsibility of being involved
in the criminal prosecution of a
president the house looks at actions and
asks
did it meet the threshold for an
impeachment if the answer is yes then
they impeach
and then the senate holds its trial and
evaluates the evidence
law enforcement can do whatever it wants
but it has nothing to do with the house
and senate so it's a red herring
but rand paul also wants to have it both
ways because it's been the same
republicans arguing for more than four
years
that you can't charge a president for
crimes committed while in office it's
sort of like a
if the president does it it's not a
legal defense and now rand paul wants it
both ways
then rand says trump has suffered enough
because his approval is down as he left
office
that's also a non-argument it's like
being saying listen
the crimes you committed were
embarrassing so we're not going to
prosecute you it doesn't work that way
so it's another
distraction and then rand paul says
in the past congress chose not to
impeach
former presidents but again it's
factually wrong
since trump was impeached while in
office
it's the trial that's happening now and
it doesn't matter
that that's how it was done in the past
the fact that in the past
choices were made one way doesn't mean
it's unconstitutional to do it
differently today and that was his main
thing that it's unconstitutional
so rand paul moving the goal posts the
question was about the constitutionality
and now he says well trump's already
been embarrassed
and you could charge him criminally and
in the past we didn't do it this way
none of that is about constitutionality
let's look at a little more
and here chris wallace just shuts it
down con constitutional scholars
which have said that the constitution
says you impeach
and disqualify if the person isn't there
to impeach you can't do either one
of them and so there are constitutional
experts senator
paul also before my colleagues senator
paul that's not quite true
if i may if i may in 1876
the then secretary of war william belnap
serving under ulysses s grant
was about to be impeached for accepting
bribes he raced to the white house and
resigned but the house impeached him
anyway
and the senate decided that it had the
authority to try him and it did
try him and although a majority sought
to remove him to convict him they didn't
get the two-thirds but isn't that
the 1876 case of william belnap
a solid precedent no because we've never
impeached a president because we always
thought it would destroy and tear up the
country and divide us further
so that's another slippery attempt from
rand paul chris wallace says
isn't my example an example of how this
clearly
is constitutional and ran says
no because that wasn't a president and
doing it to a president would divide the
country
why are we talking about dividing the
country if the initial argument rand
paul was making was about
constitutionality it's completely
pathetic but
what is what is sad you know what i i
know i've said this before but
trump saying i'm going to run for
president wacky people
choose to run for president all the time
in many countries
that's not really the problem the
problem was
that in the republican party primary
electorate
you had so many people willing to vote
for donald trump that was really
the problem and if it weren't for the
republican electorate it wouldn't make a
difference
much the same way rand paul saying this
is unconstitutional
and then when you ask him why he says
well because we did it differently in
the past
and you can file criminal charges and
trump was already embarrassed
and it would divide the country that's
not an argument about constitutionality
in an in an ideal world we would have a
level of education and media literacy
such that people would be able to hear
that and say none of what ran said has
anything to do with the issue of
constitutionality
his arguments are invalid completely
unfortunately as we talked about with
the laura ingraham case
clip earlier where she says oh we've now
it's the real insurrection is biden and
people watch and they say yeah yeah
the real insurrection is biden the low
level
of media literacy makes it so that this
stuff
actually has an effect and starts to
sort of infect
and pervade society and it's
unfortunately something that
is not easily solvable it's going to be
a long time
uh until that is completely completely
resolved so
it's disappointing we'll continue
exposing it uh but beyond that we unless
we really deal with the educational
problem in this country that's not going
to get fixed and it's a cultural problem
as well
it's a combination of the two and these
cultural education it's a cultural
educational problem
and it took decades as i've pointed out
for it to get this bad
it's not super realistic to think in six
months we're going to fix it
so it's uh it's an uphill battle to say
the least we got a really funny
voicemail
um sam cedar host of the majority report
and i
were in what as far as i knew was like a
fake feud over
youtube subscribers but really it's all
about just growing independent media
here's a caller who thought the feud was
real
and doesn't like it and also came up
with a really funny metaphor
let's listen to it yeah i just wanted to
leave a message and
let you know something because i heard
you say
the other day or a couple weeks ago on
your show
that uh or you were you were giving you
were uh
ragging on sam cedar for having more
subscribers than him
sorry um and uh
i just thought it was weird because it's
like well i'm i subscribed it
you hit the same cedar and i subscribed
to you
so i mean like turns out i i i guess you
guys are like feuding over it so like
to me it's like two bald men fighting
over a comb i i love that
two bald men fighting over a comb but i
every once in a while you know i had i
had a funny conversation with uh
with sam when this was all going on when
we were trying to get to a million
subscribers on youtube and so was he
and i said you know the reason that
every time i talk about it i say by the
way guys this is a joke
is because there are people in the
audience who think that this is serious
and uh i don't remember sam's response i
don't know if he was incredulous or what
was
or maybe he said don't worry about that
it's funny or that some people think
it's real
um i still get emails from people saying
david i think it's really disrespectful
what you're saying about sam cedar and
you know
the left shouldn't be in fighting it's
just a joke guys it's just a joke
we got to a million sam got to a million
all is good independent progressive
media is growing
and it's a great thing and we're excited
about all of it and it's all
a a fantastic thing and by the way
we are now our target now is 1.5
million youtube subscribers i know that
it seems like just yesterday we were
getting to 1 million it was actually
three three months ago
we are now almost at 1.3 million
subscribers
and it would be nuts if within 2021 we
were able to get to 1.5 million
subscribers but
that's for a future fake feud it's not
for right now
we've got a great bonus show for you
today the georgia secretary of state
has launched an investigation into
donald trump's
so-called perfect phone call asking for
11 000 votes
we will talk about that a judge has
ruled that
recreational cannabis in south dakota
is unconstitutional as written in the
measure
that was recently up for vote there and
we also have found out i don't know how
many of you saw this but there was a
streaker
in the super bowl on sunday night
apparently that was a planted streaker
by a youtuber
i'm going to talk about uh the
implications of this the importance and
uh i actually i want to talk a little
bit about the policy
that many network networks have of uh
swinging the camera away cutting away
from streakers so as not to encourage
them
by uh promoting what they're doing and
showing what they're doing
i want to talk about whether that's
effective and whether there might be
other ways to uh
to to deal with it so all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
and of course you get instant access to
the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
and live all week including today
with donald trump's second impeachment
trial we will be live on youtube twitch
and facebook
i hope you will join me i believe you
will
um and we will see uh what we get from
that i believe it
will be an illuminating experience and a
frustrating one
i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman